saba kubi explodes strategic options
including possible sale
so quibby that came out in march they
said they closed a 750 million dollar
funding round
bring in the total amount of money it
had raised to 1.75 billion dollars
quibby is the highest profile venture
launched by mr getzenberg's holding
company
uh a wonder company llc so
march they close a 750 million dollar
funding round
that's 1.75 billion dollars but march is
the beginning
of the pandemic and the shutdown so was
this quibby's fault the fact that they
don't have a good product or they didn't
do a good job marketing themselves or
are they going through the process
they're going through today because the
pandemic
combination and here's my opinion being
there i wanted to pitch quibby
uh content ideas right it was the
perfect wheelhouse for what i do
10-minute content
they were very arrogant all right they
only went after the biggest names in
hollywood period and they threw that
money around like you would not believe
this was a winning lottery ticket
if you were a big name director producer
or star in hollywood you were getting a
qibby deal
meg whitman loves big stars so does
jeffrey katzenberg plus katzenberg's a
little bit stuck
you know maybe a few years ago so they
had it in their mind because of the
money that they raised that this thing
was going to be so
so successful and it might have been but
here was their other big
big mistake that they made only for
social now it's a good selling point it
makes sense and it stood for something
or not for social for mobile so it was
only going to be on mobile but i think a
lot of people are used to watching hulu
they're watching netflix on their big
screen tv at home this was never an
option for quibby
so it could never get any traction and
that would have been the perfect time
during a lockdown to be able to watch
this on your tv at home
on the couch instead of just on your
phone not the same experience so this
thing is in the toilet they're in big
trouble now they're going to try to sell
i don't even know who would buy it
yeah i don't know much about this quibby
but let's talk about quibby's
competitors right let's talk about
capitalism competition what's out there
you got netflix obviously that's the big
one you got hulu you got amazon prime
you got hbo max you got crackle you got
cbs all access
disney plus you got acorn tv you got
youtube obviously
pluto tv shutter bit box apple tv quibby
pitch
the list goes on and on and on can they
all survive
like what was quibby's differentiating
factor that they were short for content
mobile okay so
someone's out there subscribing to all
those different platforms but can they
all survive that's my question i don't
know much about quibby but
are they on that list here's what i will
tell you okay
uh are you subscribed to netflix i i
i or hulu or amazon which one of them
just not
sorry just uh just netflix what do you
guys subscribe to
netflix and amazon i have amazon hulu
netflix and uh there's one more do you
think that
busy plus how about yourself okay so
you've got all of them espn
so you got all the luis you got it oh
i've got netflix watch this
i've got hulu yeah i've got um amazon
and i've got hbo 96 of what i use is
hulu
96. okay but you wouldn't cancel why not
cancel everything i think i must go with
i think i might okay
fine so are you are you to the point
where you would cancel it this week like
no no i won't cancel netflix because
there's enough there that i might want
and there you go so you're not going to
cancel netflix kai which one of those
you subscribe to
uh i just have netflix you just have
netflix okay so here's a tricky question
what do you got here's a tricky question
i got kids so here's a tricky question
the tricky question is what brought you
to netflix the first time
peer pressure everybody no other
competition
no no a show brought you to netflix if
you think about why you got netflix the
first time
it's because people talked about a show
that you
i have a game of thrones what's yours
it's the kevin spacey house of cards
what's yours game of thrones game of
thrones what's yours
did what what brought you to hulu what
got you to hulu
did you go there because of uh the
center from 76ers what's the guy's name
joel embiid i did that for rick and
morty hulu for rick and morty okay so
there you go you got a show how about
yourself what's yours
for me was that you had subtitles and
that's how i learned how to
so by the way that's great to know sam
what did you say
the subtitles help them learn english
from colombia kai what took you to
netflix
uh i mean i'm on a family account you're
on a family account so because it's a
benefit that comes with benefits for
free
okay so watch netflix i'm about to go to
tuscany we rent the 17
bedroom house and we're hiring chefs all
this other stuff
right before going my dad for the 50th
time
said you have to watch house of cards i
said dad i don't have netflix you have
to watch house of cards so dad i'm
telling you i'm done
so he says just watch it then all my
friends call me saying you got to watch
house of cards so i get netflix that
night and i watched 12 episodes
myself before i went to tuscany italy
that's what happened with house of cards
nothing to watch on the plane and then
we kept it and then we kept netflix
so the point is there's a couple things
here number one is
maybe they didn't have a show attractive
enough like die hard they did one with
kevin hart
you gotta have one thing that everybody
and their mothers talks about okay
that's number one you gotta have an
anchor you gotta have an anchor show
okay something that people are talking
about i bought amazon the other day you
know why
just because i wanted to watch honeyboy
honeyboy's with shyla buff i'm a
shyalabha fan it was the story of shia
labeouf with his father
so i went about honeyboy i went about
amazon i've never logged onto amazon
since i just bought it for one show
and it was honeyboy so number one they
didn't have they didn't have a product
that was attractive enough
for the rest of us to say i'm gonna buy
quibby right here's the second part
they projected 7.4 million subscribers
after only one year
only after one year you know what they
ended up with two shy of two million
okay barely hit 30 percent of the
disaster right over promise
now here's the other part here's the
other part people say it's because of
the pandemic
it's absolute bs because of the pandemic
what do you mean it's absolute bs
first of all tiger tiger was a tiger
tiger king got
65 million people watching in a span of
three weeks right
netflix had a record record-breaking
subscribership disney
crushed it with subscribership hulu
crushed you everybody pretty much
subscribed to talking hbo launch except
hbo killed it with subscribership except
for one group and that's who
quibby so i am i am not at all uh
sitting there for these guys to say well
the reason why we didn't do good is
because of the pandemic bs the pandemic
was the best thing that happened to
content creators people were laid off
sitting home watching shows you mean to
tell me
for once in your lifetime you have a
bunch of people that can watch a great
show you didn't have a good product
because of that you lost customers hey i
will say that
it's a brilliant idea it would i think
it would have worked
if not for the pandemic because
commuters on the train
i know i know but you know what it goes
back to what i said their biggest
mistake was not having it available
on you know a bigger screen that could
be it yeah that could be it
i still think it's a good show i tell
you if house of cards
was only on an app like quibby that i
could only watch on my phone and an ipad
i'd still buy it yeah but
has there been a bigger disappointment
between season one and season two in any
show other than house of cards
it seemed like they put everything into
season one and then it went downhill so
fast i never watched it again
i never watched i just watched season
one and that was it i didn't go to two
so
what happened why didn't you go to two i
i mean i got the point
you know i got the point politicians are
shady i got it you know whether that was
a story of hillary and bill or whoever
that story was about nobody knows what
it was about but it was a very
interesting story
you